cuántos de nosotros hemos sacrificado
nuestros sueños por perseguir los sueños
de los demás cuántos de nosotros no nos
amamos y aceptamos lo suficiente
cuántos hemos desaprovechado las
oportunidades que se nos presentan día
tras día
podría pasar toda la noche realizando
este tipo de preguntas para que cada uno
de ustedes
tome en consideración su vida reflexione
y haga un cambio necesario para ello
es importante que nos empodere moss a
transformar a evolucionar ya diseñar
nuestra manera de pensar de sentir y de
actuar pero muchas veces nos cuesta por
el famoso y que digan de mí
nos cuesta también porque no nos
sentimos capaces de demostrarle al mundo
quiénes somos por eso nos escondemos y
vivimos la vida ahí porque nos toca nos
llenamos de excusas nos llenamos de
miedo y un sinnúmero de cosas y son esas
mismas situaciones que no nos permiten
lograr el camino que verdaderamente
queremos para nuestra vida
es importante además que entremos en esa
reflexión qué es esto de la rebelión
humana
hacia donde realmente queremos ir y si
descomponemos a este término entendemos
que una rebelión es romper con
estructuras que son insostenibles lo que
quiere decir que no vale la pena seguir
teniéndolas
pero cuando hablamos de una rebelión
humana hablamos de algo totalmente
diferente
de diseñar los nuevos y necesarios
cambios
para leer ese potencial
pero no sabe y yo conoce su verdadero
potencial
los días donde tienen
pero yo
[Música]
es abrazar miedo
pero en él
[Música]
muchas veces
nos acompaña
[Música]
cuando uno
y un amigo
que no se te pone
y de la autonomía que nosotros seguimos
pero desde
nada más y nada menos con nosotros les
damos un poder que no es por eso tenemos
que enfocarnos en día desde otra
perspectiva de otro nombre y ahí donde
me invitó a clases
[Música]
risas
a que te tengas mayor responsabilidad
con las cosas que quieres para tu vida
dicen que debemos arriesgarnos y por qué
no y por qué no dar ese salto de fe
hacia lo nuevo y desconocido y diferente
porque no que nos limite a nosotros
mismos entonces si quieren hacer algo de
su vida láncense a cumplir lo que
verdaderamente sueña y quiere para vivir
es importante además que analicen algo
que es necesario para dar este cambio de
mentalidad o esta revolución humana
y uno de ellos es escucha a tu voz
interior
pero qué es esto de escuchar yo les
pregunto realmente ustedes están
escuchando saben cuáles son sus
necesidades y que verdaderamente quieren
para su vida
6 es pregunta
verdaderamente tiene vida
sigo ideales aunque el resto no
sí no
pero nosotros
comienzo
[Música]
de changos interior creando autos
no importa lo que el tiempo para cerrar
los ojos para comunicarme contigo
[Música]
así
y si de una necesidad
estamos haciendo de nuestra vida para
nosotros
entonces para escuchar esa voz interior
es darte cuenta que tienes que silenciar
a tu voz externa esa voz que no te deja
avanzar esa voz que no te deja cumplir
lo que verdaderamente quieres en el
camino es un reto complicado quizás
hasta muy difícil podrías decir
pero si acaso te llenas de poder y
conoces esa sabiduría que si la tienes y
está aquí conectas con tu alma conectas
con tu espíritu conectas con lo que
verdaderamente vale la pena y tiene
sentido
solamente así entiendes que esa voz está
haciendo te un llamado y te dice tú sí
tú tú debes cambiar no debes seguir la
vida que estás llevando porque no te
está proporcionando esa felicidad que
necesitas
porque no te hace sentir que la vida
realmente valga la pena
dentro de este principio también es muy
importante que se
vulnerable pero qué es esto de la
vulnerabilidad
qué es esto
es amarte y aceptarte tal y como eres y
cuando hablo de aceptarme es amarme
desde un amor real y perfecto es saber
que puedo ser de cierta forma puedo ser
de cierta manera pero no tengo que
esperar que el resto me ame si yo como
ser humano no me amo no me conozco
y es ahí cuando comprendemos que esta
idea de un amor idealizado de un amor de
cuentos de hadas o el amor de las
películas
[Música]
d
comprendemos que sólo 6 necesidades y
necesitamos
[Música]
y además
esa discapacidad quiere ser un ser un
perfecto con habilidades
y por qué se hace
juntos
o
han ido
mi deseo y mi caso lo que soy
[Música]
en realidad
es una realidad
del mundo
con su voz
porque permitir en condiciones de vida
me interesa
y esa responsabilidad que hay algunos
días
[Música]
sí
pero háganlo de la mejor manera sientan
que realmente su sangre vibra que
realmente estás enamorada con lo que
haces porque eso contribuye a hacer del
mundo un lugar mejor
pero este principio se complementa con
algo adicional y como yo siempre digo la
chapita hay que darles
y es vivan el aquí y el ahora el pasado
ya pasó el futuro no se sabe pero lo que
sí soy consciente es que estoy viva en
este momento es que tengo un compromiso
con las futuras generaciones pero más
que compromiso con ellos tengo un
compromiso conmigo
el compromiso de ser libre de
pensamientos de ideologías de me gusta
verme o ser de cierta manera porque eso
me hace feliz y eso me hace estar
presente y agradecida con el mundo por
lo que soy por lo que tengo y me amo por
la persona que soy y de esa forma puedo
dar amor al mundo
bien
porque hay una discapacidad es dios
y
aquí y como donde haremos aquí somos
conscientes y ahora ustedes
humanos que siempre humanos y él vive
más
y en la sociedad
quiero ver si tú crees
si tú crees
puedes construir
puedes trascender y puedes conectar pero
una rebelión para llegar a esta vida que
inspira a esa vida que te hace sentir y
que te hace transformar vale la pena que
la sientas aquí que la vivas todos y
cada día de tu vida porque la vida se
trata de es de vivir de soñar de creer
que cada uno de ustedes puede hacer del
mundo un lugar mejor y hoy les pregunto
realmente ustedes se van a unir a esta
rebelión humana muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]